scarlett haddad les journalistes
libanaise à l'orient le jour
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france
on a vu aujourd'hui cette visite on a
suivi en tout cas la visite d' emmanuel
macron à beyrouth une ville qui est
dévasté la population aussi qui est
dévastée et très en colère surtout cette
colère là comment vous l'interprétez à
quoi peut-elle mener
écoutez franchement parce que là la
catastrophe est tellement grande que la
colère des gens et tout à fait justifiée
vous imaginez comme ça en quelques
secondes vous regrettez votre maison
vous payez que vous avez vous retrouvé
dans la rue bon je vous n'avez vous ne
trouver personne pour vous aider enfin
l'état et dépasser les hôpitaux sont
pleins
évidemment qu'il ya une coller avec elle
et mon avis tout à fait explicables
mais au delà de la colère est ce que ça
va jusqu'à vouloir renverser d'origine
de systèmes moi je ne pense pas je pense
que c'est une réaction tout à fait
normal c'est parce que la catastrophe
est immense et que les libanais ne
sentent pas que l'état les neuf et à
l'état est présent à leurs côtés et
qu'il est en tout cas efficace il est
peut-être présent vie n'est pas efficace
donc c'est normal qu'ils aient qu'ils
éprouvent ce sentiment de colère et
qu'ils aient besoin de son actif de
dégager cette collègue s'exprimer comme
ils peuvent parce que vraiment la
catastrophe est immense vous dites que
la population libanaise que ce que
l'état est présent mais inefficace en
tout cas le sentiment qu'on a eues
aujourd'hui c'est que justement il n'ya
pas d'état au liban
qu'en pensez vous c'est à dire que c'est
certainement pas l'état efficace qu'on
veut enfin tel que quelques tout le
monde de cons voir tel que le monde
subit ni visé le combat ne peut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'état parce que
finalement à qui on voit que ça collait
à qui on adresse sa révolte
c'est à les taxer donc encore quelque
part il existe mais il n'est pas à la
hauteur des attentes des libanais il
n'est pas à la hauteur de la situation
ça c'est clair
il faut dire que la catastrophe aussi et
est beaucoup plus grande que ce qu'on
pouvait qu'on pouvait imaginer
donc oui les tailles c'est pourquoi on a
par exemple décrété un état d'urgence
pour deux semaines ce qui veut dire que
les
le côté administratif du travail de
l'état a été confié à l'armée libanaise
qui elle fait maintenant les travaux de
recensement qui essaient de trouver des
logements c'est elle qui a pris en
charge si vous voulez la gestion de la
vie quotidienne mais ça reste que
effectivement les municipalités c'est à
dire les collectivités locales ne sont
pas à la hauteur pour prendre le relais
et les gens se retrouvent ont le
sentiment d'être abandonnés à leur sort
un mot sur la situation sur place
puisque vous évoquez justement les
secours l'armée libanaise qui est sur le
terrain il y à 300 milles au moins trois
cent mille personnes aujourd'hui sans
abri à beyrouth
il ya encore des disparus que l'on
recherche sur place quelle est la
situation on sait aussi que l'aide
internationale elles commencent à
affluer
oui c'est à dire que la situation est
vraiment dramatique et plus de temps
passe plus le premier choc est dépassée
c'est à dire le premier choc de de
l'horreur qu'on a vécu là maintenant on
se heurte à tous les problèmes du
quotidien c'est-à-dire au fait qu'on n'a
pas de toit on est obligé d'aller ou
chez des membres de sa famille ou
d'essayer de mendier me demandiez à un
espace pour vous abriter il y à des
initiatives individuelles qui sont en
train d'être fait dans toutes les dents
tout et tout l'entourage de beyrouth
dans toute la ville il ya des gens qui
sont en train de fuir leur maison à ceux
qui sont dans le besoin
mais si ça reste assez limité vous avez
trois cent mille personnes à loger
il ya exactement qui sont mis à leur
disposition il ya des gens qui font ça
il ya des hôtels qui sont qui ont offert
des d'abriter ce qui n'en ceux qui n'ont
plus de toit
mais ça reste ça reste insuffisant il ya
toute la logistique qui vient avec le
quotidien c'est-à-dire comment ou ok on
trouve un toit mais il faut encore vivre
il faut se nourrit et pour soigner les
blessés il faut voir qui on a perdu où
sont nos amis où sont nos proches c'est
tout un tout un système qui est qui est
bouleversée et on a du mal nous plus de
temps passe plus le premier choc
s'éloigner plus on découvre pour bien il
est difficile de vivre à l'ombre à la
suite de cette explosion
il va falloir maintenant reconstruire
emmanuel macron il a pris des
engagements notamment il a annoncé la la
une conférence internationale de soutien
et d'appui au liban gevrey votre regard
sur le rôle que peut jouer la france
dans la reconstruction du liban et le
message aussi qu'il a adressée à classe
dirigeante un des réformes impact
politique du changement
qu'en pensez vous c'est à dire que le
contenu politique de ce qu'il a dit
n'est pas vraiment nouveau il ya deux
semaines le mise à fait exact qu'on gère
avec français était venu au liban et il
avait à peu près délivrer le même langue
le même message c'est à dire est d aider
vous pour qu'on puisse vous aider
en quel que soit le aider vous avez dit
vous avez des réformes à faire pour
regagner la confiance de la communauté
internationale pour que celle ci puisse
vous aider
maintenant l'élément nouveau que
maintenant que le président français
emmanuel macron à apporter au liban
c'est d'abord sa venue c'est un c'est
une visite qui est symbolique
déjà il ya là ne serve un bol de
l'intérêt de l'engagement de la france
aux côtés du liban un engagement dont
les libanais ont bien besoin
dans cette période où l'épreuve est
quand même très très très grand mais en
même temps il a lancé une ce que je
pense être une bonne nouvelle c'est
l'organisation d'une conférence
internationale pour le liban vous savez
que le liban depuis depuis quelques mois
enfin depuis bientôt un an est soumis à
une espèce de blocus en direct parce que
sous prétexte pour différentes raisons
dont certains disent parce qu'il ne fait
pas de report parce que le système est
pourri
d'autres disent parce que l'état ne
répond plus aux attentes du poc et
d'autres enfin les américains c'est à
dire disent que c'est à cause de
l'omniprésence du baseball à part qui
lui est en train de contrôler l'état
dont il faut punir le liban à cause du
hezbollah
donc la bonne nouvelle c'est que
apparemment c'est eto'o va un peu se
desserrer le liban devrait devenir si
vous voulez un peu aucun des nations et
enfin être l'objet d'une conférence
internationale qui est censé l'aider
maintenant est ce que les conditions
vont être un peu allégée est ce qu'à
cause de l'ampleur de la crise est ce
que la communauté internationale va être
plus indulgent si vous voulez
sur certains points c'est ce qu'on va
voir dans les prochains jours quand
l'idée parce qu'on peut utiliser va
devenir plus concret merci à vous
scarlett haddad pour cet éclairage
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
libanaise à l'orient-le jour merci pour
cette intervention en direct depuis
beyrouth merci